Hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new video. As you guys know, raids were
just released uh within the last 24
hours or so. And with them, a set of
brand new items. Um 10 maybe 8 to 10 of
them. And I'm going to try to do some
early flipping for these. Now, it's
extremely volatile. This is generally
not a very good idea. I see the price is
going up and down. Generally, it's
always trending downwards. Um, we got
the dragon sword here. Uh, pretty much
consistently been trending downwards all
the time. So, it's really easy to get
burnt. Uh, so you have to make sure you
don't leave and uh, leave your offers
in. You want to be actively here the
whole time. Uh, but we're going to give
it a shot. We're going to see how well
this goes. This is going to be day one
of maybe a couple days of doing this
while the market is still kind of on
fire. Everyone's freaking out. And yeah,
hope you guys enjoy and we'll see what
we can get with a 50 mil start. So, we
have mustered 50 mil into our inventory.
Let's just check that now. And hopefully
it won't be cut in half to 25 mil by
[__] this up too badly. But we are
going to flip raid items. They just came
out. They're extremely unstable. It's
probably not a very good idea. Um, but
I've I'm going to do it anyway. So, I've
kind of narrowed down just a couple
items that I can actually buy. Mainly
just these three for now. And since I
only have 50 mil, I might be able to
afford an ancestral hat or twisted
buckler. Uh but we'll have to see. So,
we're definitely going to start off with
the dragon throne axe cuz this seems to
be the least risky.
And uh we're just going to manually
check the margin because it's not
extremely expensive right now. Bought it
for 134
and uh sold it for
130. Uh, so yeah, I'm not sure if
there's a limit on this or if it's a
high limit. I'm not really sure anything
about this to be honest,
but uh we'll try to do like
30 maybe, 40, 50. Yeah, sure. 50. Um, if
we look at G Tracker, the amount traded
is getting up there. So, in the last uh
let's see here,
last uh half an hour hour, there's
hundreds traded. So, that does bode well
for me buying them quickly and I doubt
they'd have a limit of eight uh because
it is a consumable item. I think that is
thrown I by its name. Anyway, uh next up
we are going to try the dragon sword.
Now, because these items are brand new,
um the riskreward is extremely high
right now. So,
you can see it looks like there's a 4
mil margin on it. We definitely want to
come down here to the last traded
prices. It's crashed obviously since it
first came out, but uh now it's not.
It's like still crashing, but it might
be safe to try to buy one for super
cheap here. So maybe 22
22 23 mil
and yeah, let's try a dragon sword.
probably two 500k
and we're going to buy one of those now.
That's going to leave us with 20 mil.
And hey, look, we got a dragon thrown
axe. Nice. Okay, I kind of changed my
mind here. Since we want to have an
offer in for both the dragon sword and
the dragon harpoon cuz we really don't
have a lot of options here. Uh we're
going to go for the dragon sword a
little bit cheaper cuz then that will
allow us to afford both. So, where's
dragon sword at? Try it for 22300.
22300k
and uh the dragon harpoon
is uh I guess going to be how much money
we have left. 27565.
That seems like a reasonable price. 27.
Sure. All my money.
565k.
Let's do it. So, we bought one dragon
thrown axe. We'll try that a little more
when we have more money, but let's leave
these offers in and see how it goes.
Okay, so we actually uh did buy a dragon
harpoon. We bought it for the price we
wanted, 27565.
Uh just worth noting is I did take an
extra 3 mil out of my bank. I was trying
to do an even amount, but uh now our
initial cash is going to be 53 mil. I
did that cuz that's all I had left. And
I wanted to try buying some of the
dragon thrown axes as well, which are
slowly coming through. Uh we did manage
to flip one for 4k, so not a huge profit
or anything. Um but yeah, just wanted to
update you on that. We did buy dragon
harpoon. We're hoping to sell it for
29.7 mil. Uh which would be 1 mil 2 mil
2.2 mil profit, which would be awesome.
Uh, dragon sword still hasn't come
through, but hope it does pretty soon.
So, we did actually successfully buy a
dragon sword. Uh, and we're going to try
to find what price we want to sell it
at. Uh, cuz it is crashing all the time.
And, uh, we're going to probably go for,
let's see if we can get the day graph
loaded here.
Maybe around 25 mil. I can't even
remember what I bought it for at this
point, but uh, there's a lot more coming
into the game. It's going to
consistently be crashing, but we're
going to try putting in for 25 800k and
that should leave us with a decent
profit. All right, guys. So, we ended up
having to dump our dragon items. Now, we
didn't lose anything, which is good. Uh
cuz that would have sucked. So, now we
got a little bit more of a feel for it.
So, we're going to try buying the dragon
sword now uh for kind of our original
price here of uh 22
uh 500k. Try that. And uh we're going to
do an undercut on the dragon harpoon as
well for maybe like
25 500k. And then we're going to leave
this in for a little while and hope that
we can actually buy it for this cheaper
price. And there it is. Our first actual
flip of the day. We flipped a dragon
sword for 23800K and we ended up buying
it for 23 mil. So that is a Yeah, 23
mil. So that is a 800k profit. Pretty
good. We're going to go buy another
dragon sword now. Uh, it sold really
quickly and I left it for an hour and a
bot. Oops. Get that down there. Uh, so
let's have a look. Dragon sword.
Reload the page.
The problem is the item is constantly
going to be lowering. That being said,
uh, if we look at the dragon throne axe,
can we look at it? Um, it actually
started raising back up, which is weird.
So you can see like um but I'm assuming
for the most of the items uh that
they're just going to continue to drop.
So 23800 we sold it for
uh let's try another one for 23 mil and
uh but after that we'll probably lower
it even more. Dragon harpoon we did get
for 25500 I believe and we're going to
try to sell it for 26600. Uh mind you
these offers are only in there for about
10 minutes so far. So we'll leave this
for a little longer and then see how it
goes. So, unfortunately, we had to ditch
the dragon spear or harpoon, whatever it
is. 24 mil. That's 1.5 mil loss.
Unfortunately, that kind of counteracts
the 800k profit we had. Now, whether or
not I want to buy any more of these is
kind of
debatable cuz it just is continuing to
drop. I'll probably just lowball an
offer in because I'm leaving for about
I don't know 45 minutes even. Seems to
be too long. But yeah, it just keeps
going down and down and down. Now we're
down to 24 mil. Let's just put an offer
in for
19 19999999.
Yeah, it's down to 23 mil. So, yeah,
we'll put it in for 219999.
And yeah, we'll give that another try.
The dragon axes are still just crazy.
We're back with a dragon sword flip
completed. Uh it's going to be about
450k in profit because we bought it for
24.5 mil. See down here. Uh so not
awful. Probably not worth the risk at
this point. Uh but it did buy and sell
pretty quickly. 21499K
and leave that in there. All right guys,
so we got another dragon sword coming in
as well as more dragon throne axes. Uh
so we'll pop the throne axes in again
for about 288 900 seems to be a good
selling price. Uh, so we've actually
successfully flipped uh how many of
those? 11 at 8K. That's about 90k
profit. So, not terrible. And we'll put
those in there for 289500
or something like that. Sure. Uh, but
more importantly, the dragon sword did
come through at 21499. Uh, 219999.
And yeah, there'll be another 500k
profit. Unfortunately, the dragon sword
did sell for what we bought it for. So,
nothing lost, nothing gained. For now,
we'll put an offer in uh for just a
dragon harpoon at
2099.
So, we have some better news now. Oh,
wow. Everything just sold actually,
which is nice. Uh so, the dragon sword,
we got a 400k profit. Not too bad. the
dragon harpoon. Uh we got we'll have to
check that in a second. Actually, uh we
bought it down here for $29.99 and we
sold it for 555k profit. Pretty decent.
I think we could have got more than that
cuz we actually insta sold it back. And
uh the dragon sword, we got a
400k profit. It's pretty good, but
definitely not worth the risk. Uh well,
let's just see. We started at uh 53 ms.
We've gotten only 575k in profit so far.
Uh mainly cuz we took a pretty
substantial loss. You know what? We'll
we'll go for 21399K.
And uh the dragon sword.
Dragon sword. We're going to put it in
for $18.99
9K. Uh it seems to be dropping at a
pretty steady rate for the dragon sword.
So I think we might be able to pick it
up for this price in maybe half an hour
or so. So thankfully both my items sold
while I was at work. I had them selling
when I left because if you look at the
dragon sword now. Um it is down to 13
mil. So that would have really sucked
had we lost that. Um that being said, we
didn't really make anything on the
flips. Uh but that's okay. We're still
actually in the positive even though
we've uh done some pretty sketchy flips.
We're at uh 53 and 500K.
Not very good. So, we're going to go
ahead and try the twisted buckler. Now,
now this item has just dropped to be
cheap enough for us to flip. And uh it
has the potential to make a lot or lose
a lot.
Uh about one sold every half an hour or
so. Uh here's what the GE tracker graph
is looking like.
I don't know. It's could be anything
within this range to be fair. Maybe try
at the lower end of things just to be
safe. Maybe 39500
or something.
And it's the last it sold for. Let's
Let's lowball at 38 808
38 808k.
That is a lot of money.
All right. Put an offer in for the
twisted buckler. And uh we might
actually have enough for one of these
dragon sword to continue. Try to flip
and dragon sword.
at 119999.
Okay.
All right. So, we have a dragon sword
flip completed. I was almost 100% sure I
was the only one actually selling it at
the time. So, I probably could have got
more for it cuz we can see here. No, we
can't see. Um, if we look at the G
tracker graph, that was me $1.99 and uh
11. So, I probably could have got more
for that, but that's still 900k. Pretty
decent. We've been kind of messing
around a little bit with these. Uh,
let's see here. 11999 and 900k. Pretty
decent. We're going to probably just put
the same offer in for the dragon sword
again because it seemed to work pretty
well. And uh, if we look at the Oh my
god, wait. So many tabs.
It doesn't seem to be dropping as
quickly as it has been. So, we'll go
ahead and just put another offer in for
about 12 mil. And, uh, we want to Oh,
yeah. There's 900k. Perfect. So, we're
going to take this out and uh buy it for
a little bit more. Uh cuz we do want to
try flipping one of these cuz it looks
like it has the opportunity to make us
quite a lot. We're going to try it for
41350.
Assuming we have that much.
Well, I guess we'll find out. Perfect.
All right, guys. I'll come back with
another update. So, we did buy a twisted
buckler for 41350.
All right. All right, so now the moment
of truth. Can we sell this for a solid
profit? The last update was 46 mil.
Now
I'm just going to go for it because that
would just be amazing. Uh we'll pop it
in maybe for
4599999
and we're just going to hope for the
best. Now the problem is I have to go to
bed in like 2 hours now. So if this
doesn't sell by then, I'm not sure what
I'm going to do. But I'm pretty excited
that we managed to buy that. And if we
actually successfully flip this, that's
going to be a 5.6 mil flip, which is
going to be insane. So, I think a bit of
patience uh is going to pay off here. We
did sell the dragon sword for another
700k profit. So, that is quite nice. Um
definitely the MVP so far. Uh we are
doing these dragon thrown axe as well,
which actually have a 20k margin right
now, which is pretty sweet. Twist
Buckler has yet to sell. Uh we're going
to go ahead and buy another dragon
sword. Uh we might just lower it down a
bit cuz I don't know.
I seem to be the only one trading this
right now. So, might as well get a
little bit of a better deal. And yeah,
we'll come back when hopefully this
[__] sells.
Another dragon sword flip for another
700k. We kind of have this on lockdown
now. That was honestly only probably 10
or 15 minutes. Easy. 700K. We're going
to pop another offer in there. No
problem. Twisted buckler. We did reduce
down. Um, if we have a look at the Oh my
god, that's way too big. Uh, the graph,
it has updated with another sale at 20
or 41375.
But that being said, I'm going to hold
strong with my price. And if it is
another hour and I have to go to bed,
then I'll probably put in there for a
more reasonable price. But we're going
to risk it for uh for the monies. Oh,
I'm a little bit buttth hurt about that.
I went to go reduce down my Twisted
Buckler even more and
I sold it. So, I really could have
gotten a lot more for that. Ah, that's
what I get for being impatient.
That being said, it is still selling for
44 mil. Uh, and I only paid 41.3
mil. That's about a 3 mil flip right
there. Uh we're just going to pull our
offers out uh because it's getting a
little bit late and I really don't want
to leave these in overnight and I don't
want to get stuck with another buckler.
Uh so I think uh we're just going to
leave this for tonight. Come back in the
morning and sell these off just to see
how much we actually made
and then we'll figure out uh where to go
from there. So we started with uh 53 mil
at the beginning of the day and we're
ending at 58.6 mil. Not bad. I feel like
I could have gotten a little better just
with how volatile the items are, but
honestly, I can't complain. I could have
easily been down 10 mil at the same
time. I um kind of lucked out in some
ways. Uh but also, I was attentive
paying attention and it did end up
paying off. So, hope you guys enjoyed.
If you want to see another uh kind of
just a day of flipping uh the new items
like this, please toss toss the video a
like uh because I will know then to
prioritize getting this out or uh
otherwise I will probably still do it
but it might take a little longer. Okay
guys, thanks for watching as always and
I will see you guys in the next video.
[Music]